Hey so a lot of people called my
attention Pat to Morning Joe on MSNBC
and they said hey morning Joe Joe
Scarborough seems to be on board with
what you said about Donald Trump's
mental state David so the background is
months ago we did a story about at what
level is Donald Trump leading appeared
that the guy could barely read above a
third or fourth grade level and then
subsequently on March 30th I believe it
was we did a story about Donald Trump's
cognitive state is he showing some of
the early signs of dementia or
Alzheimer's and we did a pretty detailed
report about this the last 48 hours as
well as the string of interviews that
trumped it around the hundred day mark
are fueling the concerns of many people
that there is something seriously
cognitively wrong with Donald Trump tons
of people emailed me saying David does
Joe Scarborough host of Morning Joe on
MSNBC watch your show because now he's
talking about Donald Trump's mental
state let's take a look at the video
from Morning Joe I want to talk about
what's happened over the past 24 hours
presidential historian David Doug
Brinkley said describe the president's
confused middle State yeah I saw the
transcripts from just the the rambling
of talking about Andrew Jackson and the
Sybil we've seen him try to bluff his
way through things before but you take
that and John Dickerson it was really
really shocking
it would Dickerson he was mumbling
rambling around incoherent that will
show it act and then just sort of quit
tired and walked off was that we have it
we have the dickerson I blind up so now
we're getting that Jon Meacham we of
course can ask it an easy question about
Andrew Jackson obviously he was wrong
about Andrew Jackson in the Civil War
fight matter of about 15 years I want to
ask you the more difficult question do
you follow Douglas Brinkley in your
assessment that the President of the
United States
certainly over the past 48 hours has
appeared to have a quote confused mental
state
I doubt Joe Scarborough watches our show
he might I don't know for sure but yes
we've been on this story for more than a
month remember our story from March 30th
here's just a few seconds of it I want
to give you some background on this next
story I'm going to talk about a lot of
people have been emailing me saying
David you know what you've identified as
Donald Trump's lack of comfort in
reading may actually be part of a
broader cognitive decline that Donald
Trump might be experiencing some kind of
early stage dementia or Alzheimer's and
that that may actually be what's behind
the erratic behavior the obfuscation the
weird rants with with very limited
seemingly limited vocabulary and I
received a blog post yesterday from a
blogger who goes by the name of the
neuro critic who has outlined the case
quite specifically for Donald Trump's
suffering from some kind of cognitive
decline so it needless to say you can
check out the entire video on our
youtube channels about eight and a half
minutes long the point is people are
clearly waking up to this reality Donald
Trump is clearly narcissistic he's
clearly paranoid he's clearly histrionic
as well as delusional but those are sort
of characteristics cited colloquially
it's not really a diagnosis of any kind
this is not a surprise though this has
been the case and pretty obvious with
Donald Trump for a year and a half and
in addition Trump's incompetent but
that's sort of a different story
altogether
the Republican Party is going to stand
behind Trump and it could be four years
unless he does something so egregious
that they might say well we've got to
look at the 25th amendment invoking the
25th amendment to get Trump out of here
he'd have to start calling the
interviewer racial slurs or I mean the
fact that he's clueless can sort of be
muddled with the fact that he's unstable
and unless he really goes out of his way
and and for example calls a black in
reviewing an interviewer the n-word or
something like that I think Republicans
are basically going to stand behind the
guy especially because Trump's doctor
Harold Bernstein is not going to admit
that Trump has one of these conditions
yeah and I also think that it's going to
be a very sensitive topic for reporters
to go after him on because if you're
dealing with you know some sort of
user a mental health issue absolutely
it's going to have negative
repercussions to some of these people's
careers they may not even touch the
issue and not only that it could be seen
as offensive in some way if you don't
deal with it because it's not something
to make fun of if someone has dementia
or Alzheimer's or cognitive decline if
it's the president of the United States
who's deciding who do we bomb and who do
we go to war with and they're
experiencing cognitive decline it's
significantly newsworthy but it wouldn't
be something to make fun of and we've
got to make sure that in the discussions
of it and I think we're doing a
perfectly fine job of it
we're not saying that it would be
something to laugh at if that were the
case it would just be very disturbing
and concerning you know if you have a
disability there's certain occupations
that you can't hold yes certainly when
you're dealing with the most powerful
man on the entire planet there should be
you know different qualifications for
that job more so than just are you old
enough have you been living here long
enough there should be better tests from
that no doubt about it and we will see
who else jumps aboard this train Joe
Scarborough from MSNBC the most recent
to do it